bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux alors j'interromps votre
programme de l'été pour ce flash spécial
d'information puisque l'actualité
paléontologique de juillet août a été
très très chargé d'habitude ça se calme
un peu en juillet-août niveau
publication mais là cette année il ya
plein de trucs très intéressant qui sont
sortis donc on va faire notre rappaz
rattrapage de l'été plus tôt que prévu
donc vous inquiétez pas les cours de
raffaella non sur la taphonomie vont
arriver comme prévu comme je voulais
annoncé dans la dernière vidéo sur la
paléo neurologie mais ils vont arriver
la semaine prochaine ne vous en faites
pas c'est juste un léger retard ce n'est
qu'un retard c'est tout donc aujourd'hui
on va faire les le rattrapage des
actualités tant qu'on est à parler
d'actualité d'ailleurs je vous précise
si vous n'avez pas vu les lives de miss
plume c'est normal désolé j'ai annoncé
en début d'été que miss plume frais des
live mais c'était sans compter le fait
qu'il mettrait plus de deux mois à
réparer l'ordinateur qui devait nous
permettre de faire des lives
l'ordinateur que j'utilise maintenant
n'a pas ce qu'il faut dans le ventre
pour encaisser un live sur twitter un
stream sur twitch donc voilà je peux pas
faire de streaming avec cet ordinateur
là il faut attendre d'avoir l'autre
ordinateur mais il n'est pas encore
réparées ça fait deux mois je vous
assure que ça m'embête beaucoup plus que
n'importe qui d'autre
bon alors les actualités paléontologique
de l'été on commence avec qui dit été
dit plage et qui dit plage dire qu'à et
qui dira qu'un dit megalodon
megalodon dont 57 26
via de publier un article vraiment super
intéressant parce que c'est vraiment le
l'article qui donne le plus de détails
sur la biologie de megalodon jusqu'à
aujourd'hui jamais on avait atteint je
pense ce niveau de détail en tout cas en
termes de connaissances évidemment il ya
des gens ce dont on va parler là sur la
biologie de mégalo dont il ya des gens
qui avaient déjà fait des tas de
théories dessus mais c'était vraiment
basé sur généralement le truc avec
megalodon c'est qu'on n'en connaît que
les dents et quelques vertèbres et c'est
tout en tout cas jusqu'à présent on ne
connaissait que quelques dents et
quelques vertèbres bon beaucoup de dents
quand même mais du coup c'est très
difficile d'arriver à savoir des choses
sur bungalows dont c'est très facile
d'arriver à faire des hypothèses sont
megalodon c'est très difficile de savoir
des choses sur megalodon
et puis tout le reste du squelette est
en cartilagineux c'est extrêmement
compliqué de fait d'avoir des des baux
fossiles de megalodon bon bah là dans
cet article on nous propose 7 cette
nouvelle série de vertèbres de megalodon
que je vous affiche maintenant à l'écran
voilà cette série de vertèbres de
megalodon ses 140 et une vertèbre de
megalodon attribué à megalodon qui ont
été découverts à anvers en belgique en
dans les années 1860 et quelques quand
ils construisaient la forteresse là bas
donc elles datent du milieu scène de la
fin du miocène ses vertèbres elles
n'étaient pas associés à cette mâchoire
cette mâchoire là que vous voyez là
c'est un composite donc ça c'est le
spécimen tel qu'il était au musée de
bruxelles en
1923 si je ne m'abuse moi c'est un
squelette qui est là depuis très
longtemps mais qui a été décrit très
sommairement dans les années 1920 et qui
depuis a été un peu a été un peu oublié
et donc ce que cet article d'enseignants
de 7,26 nous propose c'est une nouvelle
finalement de une nouvelle approche de
cette colonne vertébrale de megalodon
afin d'en apprendre plus sur le grand
requin megalodon et sur sa biologie est
donc déjà balle à la première question
c'est l'attribution de cette colonne
vertébrale au
au megalodon bon de toute façon déjà
rien que vu la taille des vertèbres en
question ça vous
montrer une petite image là voyez on va
voir homme avec une barre d'échelle ici
voyez que la
voyez là là vous avez toute la colonne
vertébrale ici avec l'échelle qui donne
un maître comme ça donc voyez que c'est
quand même une colonne vertébrale qui
est balèze il estime à près de 11 mètres
de long
elle est attribuée à un seul animal
parce qu'ils ont plus qu ont ils ont pu
compter en fait les lignes de croissance
il ya des lignes de croissance sur les
vertèbres de requins ils ont pu compter
les lignes de croissance et sur toutes
les vertèbres sur lesquels ils ont pu
faire le compte toutes les vertèbres qui
était suffisamment complète ils ont
compté un âge de 46 ans le vénérable
pour un requin c'est très très vénérable
mais en tout cas ça montre que tout les
vertèbres ont le même âge donc qu'elles
appartenaient au même individu du coup
enfin du moins que tout les vertèbres
appartiennent à un individu qui est mort
à l'âge de 46 ans les vertèbres date du
miocène les vertèbres non pas 46 ans
c'est à toi que je m'adresse là la
personne la personne qui croit que le
megalodon est encore vivant aujourd'hui
c'est parce je viens pas de dire que les
vertèbres ont 46 ans j'ai dit les
vertèbres appartiennent à un individu
qui est mort à l'âge de 46 ans par
contre il est mort à l'âge de 46 ans il
ya plusieurs millions d'années un nom le
méga l'on dort le megalodon est
complètement éteint et il n'y a aucun
doute là dessus n'en déplaise à
l'internet n'en déplaise à tout
l'internet du bullshit j'ai même envie
de l'appeler bref donc ce ses vertèbres
déjà bon elles sont très très grosse
entaille absolue ce qui déjà empêche
l'attribution à tout un tas de requins y
compris le requin blanc elles sont trop
grandes pour être des vertèbres de
requins blancs restent les requins
pèlerins et les requins baleines et le
megalodon et d'autres requins de grande
taille bon c'est ses vertèbres sont
quand même suffisamment distinctive de
tous les autres requins de grande taille
connu pour pouvoir les attribuer à
megalodon est historiquement elles ont
été attribuées à megalodon parce qu'elle
ressemble beaucoup
à celle du grand requin blanc alors je
sais je ne vous en faites pas que
megalodon n'était pas un proche parent
du requin blanc mais megalodon est un
analogue écologique aux requins blancs
ce qui veut dire que ses dents
ressemblent beaucoup à celles du requin
blanc parce qu'il se nourrissait de la
même chose et donc son squelette
ressembler aussi beaucoup à celui du
requin blanc puisque il servait à
accomplir la même chose à savoir
attraper des mammifères marins donc
c'est ce sont tous les deux des macros
prédateurs de mammifères marins de fait
ils se ressemblent beaucoup mais parce
qu'on appelle la convergence évolutive
donc la convergence évolutive est réel
entre megalodon et le grand requin blanc
ce qui fait que la ressemblance des
vertèbres avec celle d'un requin blanc
est valide pour l'attribution à
megalodon même s'il n'était pas
apparentés oui je sais c'est tordu comme
raisonnement mais bon en tout cas voilà
l'attribution est quand même
relativement robuste il ya cent quarante
et une vertèbre donc c'est la plus
longue colonne vertébrale qu'on a réussi
à retrouver complète as d'un seul
individu 2 megalodon et qui ne soit pas
juste publié sur un skyblog 1 là on est
dans de la vraie littérature
scientifique donc cette colonne
vertébrale est estimé avoir appartenu à
un animal qui faisait à peu près 16
mètres de long alors 16 mètres de long
avec une colonne vertébrale de 11 mètres
pourquoi cette différence va tout
simplement parce qu'il faut rajouter la
tête et qu'il faut rajouter là que hé
oui
la tête donc elle a été estimée la
taille de la tête a été estimé à partir
d'une mâchoire qui a été retrouvé en
amérique du nord alors la mâchoire était
pas articuler puisque encore une fois le
crâne d'un megalodon aurait été
cartilagineux comme celui de tous les
requins mais les dents et ont été
retrouvés en association et donc on pur
ont pu être repositionné de façon
raisonnable pour reconstituer une
mâchoire complète et donc cette mâchoire
complète indique a été elle-même
reconstituée
de façon virtuelle exactement comme la
colonne vertébrale
afin de reconstituer la taille de crâne
possible de megalodon le reste de la
viande est ce temps étant estimée là
tout ce que vous voyez là étant estimé à
partir du requin blanc puisque comme je
les dis le requin blanc être reste
encore le meilleur analogue qu'on a deux
megalodon donc tout ça c'est des
hypothèses raisonnables et donc ça donne
une taille de 16 mètres de long pour
megalodon ce qui est raisonnablement ce
qu'on avait réussi quand même à dire à
partir de la taille des dents puisque
les dents de megalodon sont à peu près
deux à trois fois plus grande que celle
d'un requin blanc donc on s'imaginait un
animal qui étaient deux à trois fois
plus grand 40 qu'un requin blanc donc
dans les alentours de 15 18 m donc on a
enfin une réponse à la question quelle
était la véritable longueur dames et
galop dont voilà autour d'une de autour
de 16 m voilà ça au moins la réponse on
la sait fait le poids de megalodon est
estimé à 60 et une tonne ce qui est à
peu près dix à vingt fois celui d'un
grand requin blanc c'est beaucoup c'est
le poids à peu près
on est dans l'ordre de grandeurs des
cétacés l'un des baleines même j'ai
envie de dire
avec un poids de 60 et une tonne et donc
donc ce poids de 60 et une tonne ayant
été estimé à partir justement de deux
ses estimations de volume un fait est
fait de façon virtuelle
et ça ça donne une idée à ça ça donne
quelque chose d'intéressant puisque ça
me permet de dire en gros de donner une
ligne de réflexion on va dire un minimum
sur le régime alimentaire de megalodon
c'est à dire que pour entretenir un
animal de 60 tonnes avec un métabolisme
de requins et donc probablement proche
de celui du requin blanc et ce
métabolisme devait être relativement
élevé parce qu'un animal de soixante et
une tonne voyait qu'eux on dépasse
largement alors là c'est ce qui vous est
représenté sur ce graphe en bleu vous
avez les animaux etc terme en rouge vous
avez les animaux mais au terme alors
soit parce qu'ils ont un métabolisme
très élevés comme c'est de là soit parce
qu'ils sont devenus trop grands pour
évacuer leur chaleur c'est ce qu'on
appelle la gigue en termine donc la
gigue en termes hisser quand en fait
vous êtes tellement gros vous avez un
volume tellement élevé que même en étant
à sang froid en fait la seule activité
de vos muscles la chaleur dissipée par
là
la chaleur produite par l'activité de
vos muscles ne peut pas être dissipé
parce que vous êtes trop volumineux donc
c'est ça qu'on appelle la gigue en
terminait megalodon évidemment crève le
plafond de la gigue en de la gigue en
tout est remis donc megalodon devait
avoir un métabolisme relativement élevé
pour un requin est donc couplé avec ce
poids de 60 et une tonne ça vous donne
une base pour réfléchir sur la quantité
de nourriture que megalodon devait
ingurgiter pour juste simplement rester
en vie voilà pour alimenter ses soixante
et une tonne de viande
quotidiennement et donc ce qu'ils
estiment ici c'est que donc megalodon
devait devait ingurgiter quasiment 100
mille calories par jour ce qui
représente à peu près 21 kilos de pure
graisse de baleine par jour ou alors vu
que les requins ont aussi un foie qui
est très riche en graisses c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que les orques tu les requins
les et ventre pour manger spécifiquement
leur leur foi c'est pas par cruauté
c'est parce que le foie est extrêmement
riche en graisses donc ils vont verts
eelv ont déjà ils vont prendre le fois
parce que c'est quasiment de la grèce
pur c'est très facile à digérer
contrairement au reste qui est plein de
dos ou de ou de tissus plein de
collagène le collagène qui est plus dur
à digérer avec la grèce du coup on va
vers le foie le fois c'est impec c'est
plein de grèce c'est de là quasiment de
la grèce pur chez les requins parce
qu'ils s'en servent d'organes de
flottaison il utilise le fait que la
grèce soit plus légère que l'eau donc 21
21 tonnes de graisse de baleine ou 21 kg
par une vingtaine tonnes 21 kilos de
graisse de baleine ou 17 kg de foie de
requin par jour devait suffire à
alimenter un megalodon est donc ce
qu'ils disent ici c'est que ça
représente seulement 0,1 pour cent d'une
orque c'est juste à titre comparatif ça
veut pas dire que megalodon s'attaquer
aux orques spécifiquement mais à titre
de comparaison ça représente juste 0 1%
de du nord que de 2,6 tonnes ou ça
représente 28% d'un grand requin blanc
donc en fait megalodon en fait que ce
que ce qu'ils sont en train de nous
expliquer là c'est que leurs estimations
ah et leurs estimations de métabolisme
en fait ne sont pas excessifs ils sont
ils sont dans ce conte ils sont dans le
bios logiquement possible parce que 0 1%
du nord que c'est pas grand chose donc
six s'ils sont si longs juste dans leur
estimation ça veut dire que megalodon
pouvait tuer un grand cétacé donc par
exemple les sept auteurs qui sont les
les baleines à fanons qui peuplaient à
l'époque le
les océans dont qu'il pouvait tuer des
grands cétacés est sans nourrir pendant
plusieurs jours sur la même carcasse
sans trop de problème en fait donc ils
ont deux se lasse il assiste en fait
c'est pas tellement
voici ce qu'est la biologie de megalodon
que la biologie qu'on reconstitue est
raisonnable voilà c'est vraiment ça le
point de le propos ici qui vous est
présentée c'est que c'est une biologie
qui est très raisonnable en réalité 60
et une tonnes de requins soixante et une
tonne de mégalo dont ça se maintient
relativement facilement et donc on avait
parlé dans le dernier paléo news
justement est-ce que le megalodon était
un super prédateur donc c'est à dire un
prédateur de prédateurs est-ce qu'il se
nourrissait de dauphin et de pinnipèdes
c'était ça la question ou est-ce qu'il
se nourrissait de
cette eau terre donc de baleines qui
sont beaucoup plus basses dans la chaîne
alimentaire que les pinnipèdes et les
dauphins bon ben là ce que nous dit cet
article c'est que se nourrir d'orques
par exemple donc se nourrir de super
prédateur c'était tout à fait possible
ça suffisait à megalodon et il donne
toute une liste en bas de proies
potentielles
avec notamment est ce que il aurait dû
les consommer complètement est donc là
vous voyez jusque lors qu et même le
requin blanc ici il dit oui et après
donc sur à cette hauteur sur les cétacés
les baleines à fanons là par contre ils
ne pouvaient ils n'étaient pas obligés
de les consommer complètement
là il aurait pu tenir très longtemps sur
des sur des baleines sur des baleines à
fanons
et comme on l'a vu les orques aussi vous
voyez que les orques sont vraiment juste
avant la gestion complète
qu' on est on est vraiment sur des
estimations biologiques qui sont très
raisonnables et même surprenamment basse
du coup j'ai envie de dire puisque
finalement on s'attendrait à ce que
megalodon soit une espèce de monstre
qu'ils doivent manger longueur de temps
c'est d'ailleurs ce que les films nous
sortent allons le dire si vous avez vu
ce mec le machin passe littéralement son
temps à bouffer on aurait pu dire que
c'était raisonnable pour entretenir sa
masse mais en finale n'ont en tout cas
certainement pas des humains le
megalodon n'aurait pas perdu son énergie
physiologique à chasser des pauvres
petits humains des pauvres petits
humains avec leurs pauvres 5% de graisse
dans un corps de d'à peine 70 kg à
l'époque le l'humain le plus humain que
megalodon auraient pu croiser sachant
qu'il s'est éteint il ya deux millions
d'années ça aurait était homo habilis et
peut-être les tout premiers homo erectus
puisque a dream aullène en afrique du
sud ils ont retrouvé les plus anciens
homo erectus un petit peu plus vieux que
deux millions d'années
ça ce sont des ouais ce sont des
hominidés qui aurait fait ouais 60 kg à
peu près donc 60 kg avec 5% de grèce ça
n'intéresse pas un megalodon donc no
homo erectus vend pas on sait que les
premiers représentants du genre homo et
les australopithèques était pas fan du
milieu côtier
il était on retrouve quasiment jamais
leur reste sur le milieu côtier le
milieu côtier c'est vraiment un truc qui
a été conquis par homo sapiens
dont qu'il n'était pas fan du milieu
côtier du tout mais s'il l'avait été
s'il avait piqué une une nage il
n'aurait pas été embêtés par megalodon
megalodon n'aurait pas en tout cas un
megalodon adultes de 16 mètres de long
n'aurait pas été intéressé par un pauvre
petit australopithèques ou un pauvre
petit homo erectus c'est pas c'est pas
assez nutritifs le megalodon devait
vraiment s'attaquer à des gros
mammifères marins qui produisent quand
même beaucoup de graisse ou bien à
d'autres requins comme le requin blanc
il lui fallait une certaine quantité de
graisse quand même pour survivre qu'il
n'aurait pas trouvé chez un humain donc
un humain ne serait pas embêtés par un
megalodon adultes absolument pas ce sont
des mensonges
les films vous raconte des mensonges et
puis il ya d'autres formations qui sont
distillées dans cet article par exemple
ils estiment la vitesse de croisière de
megalodon vu qu'ils ont une
une silhouette complète grâce à cette
colonne vertébrale ils peuvent
reconstituer une silhouette complète
donc ils peuvent estimer la taille la
vitesse de croisière du megalodon à cinq
km heure donc un être humain bien
entraînés peut nager plus vite qu'un
megalodon en vitesse de croisière
c'est intéressant je pense après je
parle vraiment d'un être humain
olympique 1 par contre là parce que faut
être nageur olympique pour nager
significativement plus vite que 5 km
heure c'est pas évident évident à nager
vite quand on est un primate donc voilà
il ya tout tout cet article vraiment est
très très très intéressant donc je vous
le mets en description c'est que du bon
et maintenant on a vraiment du matos
c'est surtout ça l'important avec cet
article c'est que les c'est l'estimation
de taille qu'on avait le megalodon qui
était comme je le disais de 15 à 18
mètres elle était juste basée uniquement
sur les dimensions des dents elle était
juste mais ça n'était qu'une hypothèse
maintenant on a vraiment une colonne
vertébrale qui dont les vertèbres mises
bout-à-bout vous mettre vous bornes déjà
cette dimension vous voyez vous donne
vraiment une base de réflexion et c'est
ça qui est très intéressant avec cet
article c'est que maintenant on a une
vraie base de réflexion et je trouve ça
encore plus hallucinant quand on se dit
que c'était là depuis 1860
bonds est en réalité on aurait dû
demander à nos ancêtres homo erectus de
tout écrire mais bon
évidemment les crédits en n'ayant pas
été inventé à l'époque le rapport de nos
ancêtres homo erectus ne nous auraient
pas pu nous parvenir mais en tout cas
voilà depuis 1860 on a cette colonne
vertébrale et maintenant elle a été elle
a été je pense exploiter pour pour en
tirer le jus paléo biologique et ça
c'est très très intéressant c'est
d'autant plus intéressant qu'il ya un
autre article qui est paru cette fois
dans une autre revue prestigieuse qui
s'appelle proceedings of the royal
society be for biology by b pour
biologie donc
qui décrit des crânes de cachalot enfin
ou du moins d'ancêtre de cachalot qu'on
appelle les filles étaient rides et des
crânes de cachalot avec des grosses
traces de morsures
sur le museau enfin il est les dauphins
enfin les cachalots n'ont pas de museau
puisqu'en réalité leur nez s'élévant
donc il est sur le sommet du crâne donc
techniquement le museau c'est le sommet
du crâne mais vous voyez ce que je veux
dire ils ont une espèce de rostre et
donc sur son rostre il y a des traces de
morsures de requins et ça c'est très
intéressant on sait pas si c'est
megalodon le grand requin blanc
évidemment juste des traces de morsures
c'est pas possible de distinguer le
megalodon du grand requin blanc mais ce
qui est très intéressant c'est que ces
traces de morsures se trouve pile là où
chez les cachalots on retrouve ce qu'on
appelle le sperme à c'est y qui est une
substance blanche
et rebbie leuze d'où son nom sperme à
sétif le sperme de baleines
littéralement qui n'est pas du sperme de
baleine mais c'est en fait l'organe qui
permet de produire en du moins qui
permet d'amplifier les ultrasons donc
c'est un amplificateur d'ultrasons
qu'ils ont sur le museau qu'on appelle
le melon chez les dauphins mais là chez
le ch et les cachalots on l'appelle
spécifiquement le sperme à city et ce
sperme à ses ti donc est 100% fait de
grèce et ça ça va du coup voir des
empreintes de dents des traces de
morsures de requins et possiblement de
megalodon puisque ce sont des animaux
qui vivaient là dans la piste aux
formations donc la formation pisco dans
au pérou donc ils étaient contemporains
de megalodon à l'époque eh bien ça ça
soutient parfaitement que megalodon où
les grands requins blancs qui vivaient
aussi à l'époque parce que il y avait
aussi déjà des grands requins blancs ça
soutient qu' il s' attaquer
spécifiquement aux parties graisseuse
donc exactement l'histoire que nous
raconte finalement cette colonne
vertébrale donc tout est cohérent et
tout ça c'est sorti cet été voyez la
dernière fois c'est marrant parce que la
dernière fois j'ai eu j'avais deux
articles sur le megalodon qui était
complètement contradictoire là
maintenant j'ai deux articles sur le
megalodon mais qui sont cohérents l'un
qui vous dit il fallait qu'ils mangent d
une certaine quantité de graisse pur
pour survivre par jour et celui là donc
il vous montre des preuves directes 2
consommation de graisses pur
par le megalodon ou des grands requins
blancs là évidemment ils vous ont
surtout représenté megalodon balle ceci
dit celui-là c'est un grand requin blanc
ça c'est megalodon ça c'est un grand
requin blanc donc là on est quand même
sur des preuves
de première main j'ai envie de dire 2
consommation de graisses d'organes
graisseux de de ciblage j'ai envie de
dire des organes graisseux par les
grands requins contemporain de ses
ancêtres des cachalots donc ça je trouve
ça carrément ouf issime d'avoir à la
fois l'article qui fait l'hypothèse que
basé sur les restes de megalodon et à
côté de ça presque publié en même temps
un autre article qui confirme que
megalodon et où le grand requin blanc
les grands requins blancs du pliocène de
la formation pisco consommer
spécifiquement de la graisse de baleine
est donc cet organe qui s'appelle le
sperme ascétique correspond aux melons
des dauphins donc là on est quand même
on est quand même sur un très très haut
niveau de cohérence scientifique c'est
là où je veux en venir on est sur un
très très haut niveau de cohérence
scientifique on est sûr on est sur
quelque chose qui a l'air de tenir la
route on continue avec les prédateurs
iconique du passé mais on remonte cette
fois beaucoup plus loin dans le passé on
remonte au crétacé et on va voir du côté
de tyrannosaurus avec cet article paru
dans evolutionary biology
qui revient sur l'hypothèse en fait que
le genre tyrannosaurus au lieu d'être
composé d'une seule espèce rex devait
être composé de trois espèces j'en avais
fait toute une vidéo je vous la mettrait
en descriptions donc il ya eu un article
paru il ya quelques mois de cela qu'ils
proposent est de diviser le genre
tyrannosaurus en trois espèces notamment
basé sur la robustesse des eaux et sur
la morphologie des incisives donc les
trois espèces et un rex
imperator et reggina donc le roi
l'empereur et la reine basiquement des
tyrans des dinos des lézards tyran
cet article il est il est publié par des
grands experts en matière de biologie
des tyrannosauridés donc vous avez
notamment david own vous avez thomass
car vous avez stephen brusatte vous avez
thomass paultes donc là on a les autres
je les connais pas mais là déjà avec ces
quatre là vous avez littéralement la
fine fleur de des autorités en matière
de biologie des tyrannosauridés il
manque littéralement que phil kerry je
vois pas fils que riz dans la liste des
auteurs mais littéralement c'est le seul
qui manque dans cette liste d'auteurs
pour avoir le quinté gagnant de la
biologie des tyrannosauridés et ces gens
ne sont absolument pas d'accord avec la
division de tyrannosaurus rex en trois
espèces
et j'aurais plutôt tendance comme vous
si vous avez vu la vidéo que j'ai fait
déjà plus tôt sur cette hypothèse de la
division de tyrannosaurus en régie n'a
imperator et rex vous savez déjà que
pareil j'ai des doutes sur cette
hypothèse mais donc là c'est confirmé
par ces doutes sont soutenus du moins
pas confirmé mais soutenu par ses
experts en la matière
l'une des premières la première raison
qui est évoquée donc dans cette figure
c'est que déjà la définition même de
tyrannosaurus imperator
et pardonne parce que tyrannosaurus
imperator s'est littéralement exactement
comme tyrannosaurus rex mais le nombre
d' incident d'incisives est différent
donc en fait imperator comme vous voyez
ici vous voyez donc on avait tous les
tyrannosaures qui était robuste à deux
incisives vous avez regina qui est
gracile à une incisive
et enfin une assise yves je crois que
c'était la taille de l'incisif qui
changeait bref vous pouvez retourner
voir la vidéo que j'avais fait pour en
savoir plus sur cette histoire
d'incisives
et l'a donc vous avez rex qui est dont
la mono philly donc dont la validité
j'ai envie de dire est soutenu par le
fait que pareille son nombre d'incisives
est réduit à une incisive et donc à père
à tort lui vous voyez sa branche a là
rien et concrètement ça veut dire que
imperator est définie par rien en fait
donc ça fait dé facto de imperator un
groupe mal défini un groupe paraphe il
éthique on appelle ça déjà un problème
avec la définition même de ces espèces
même si même en considérant que les
arguments avancés dont celui des
incisives et celui de la robustesse des
eaux était valide on aurait déjà un
problème au niveau de la définition d'un
père à tort le deuxième problème basse
et 7 fameux problème de robustesse chez
tyrannosaurus il ya des hauts il ya des
morts feu robuste et des mof gracile
donc des mof haus épais et des mof haus
plus tôt fin et le problème c'est que
quand vous quand vous quantifier cette
robustesse et que vous en faites un beau
diagramme comme ce qui vous est présenté
là vous avez les spécimens rangés par
robustesse errants et colorisé par
appartenance à un imperator regina où
rex imperator en rose regina envers rex
en bleu à huy et mal est pas défini en
violet le rose et le violet c'est
terrible bon bref et donc vous voyez que
c'est conçu tout mélanger voilà c'est
toute façon c'est pas tellement
important de 7,7 de s'arrêter sur les
couleurs vous voyez que c'est tout
mélanger sur l'arbre sur l'arbre b
quelle que soit la façon il explique la
dans la dans la légende delà de cette
image comment ils ont fait pour
reconstituer ces arbres c'est ce qu'on
appelle un cluster c'est pas une analyse
phylogénétique phylogénétique dans ce
cas-là ça s'appelle un cluster
mais ceux de deux bases si c'est tout
mélanger c'est que c'est plutôt pas
terrible voilà c'est plutôt pas terrible
alors là vous avez peut-être un petit
kloster de rose dans ce coin là un petit
cluster de verre mais vous voyez là
chaque fois il ya un autre truc qui
vient s'y mettre là vous voyez quels
bleus irex et là vous voyez est la cm 15
01 67 qui viennent à se mettre au milieu
des verts ce qui veut dire que
globalement
ça marche pas on a globalement la
robustesse ne permet pas de classifier
en fait les tyrannosaures donc d'une
part ces invalides balleux ces invalides
l'espèce regina et
et la broche imperator puisque vous
voyez que regina notamment étaient
définis par sa gracilité donc si on ne
peut pas distinguer de façon
sur les mauves gracile et les mof
robuste alors ça invalides déjà regina
après c'est intéressant dans le sens où
ça confirme par contre que cette idée
d'avoir des morts frau buste et des
mauves gracile de tyrannosaurus c'est
pas si bien soutenu que ça on en avait
déjà parlé la dernière fois en disant
qu' il y avait une continuité en fait
entre le more from august et le mord
gracile avec tout un continuum de
robustesse entre robuste et gracile donc
là sa tante a confirmé cette observation
et du coup comme dans l'hypothèse où
tyrannosaurus était une seule un seul et
même groupe il ya des gens qui ont
proposé que les robustes et et les
femelles et les grassi des télés mal
peut-être que l'histoire est un peu plus
compliqué que ça mais bon là c'est pas
cette hypothèse là qui est testé ici ça
reste quand même on reste quand même
avec cette idée que les morts feu
robustes sont les seuls à avoir montré
de l'os médullaire à savoir de l'eau ce
qui est typique chez des oiseaux
femelles puisqu'il sert à faire
alimenter la coke ide en calcium donc
pour l'instant il ya que les morts
robuste qui ont produit de l'os
médullaire mais si la classification
entre robuste et gracile
ne tient plus ça va devenir compliqué de
continuer à parler de tyrannosaurus
mallet tyrannosaurus femelles pour
parler de grâce il est robuste
respectivement bon mais ça encore une
fois c'est pas ce qui est testé dans
cette analyse en particulier donc on va
pas s'étaler trop longtemps là dessus en
tout cas ça invalides l'argument de
robustesse pour la séparation de regina
et donc ils restent là l'argument des
incisives donc les fameuses grosses et
petites incisive dont il nous explique
que la distribution en fait de ce
caractère est essentiellement due aux
taux de remplacement des incisives
donc ça n'a rien à voir avec une
séparation taxonomique donc pour eux le
tyrannosaurus rex reste un et
indivisible
voilà il n'ya qu'une seule espèce de
tyrannosaurus est ces essais
tyrannosaurus rex on reste avec les
dinosaures et cette fois on va parler un
petit peu des oiseaux parmi les
dinosaures théropodes et cette étude
très intéressante qui nous montrent
qu'en fait donc si vous connaissez votre
biologie des dinosaures vous savez que
les dinosaures ont été historiquement
divisée en deux groupes les sauts risque
ya littéralement bassin de reptiles avec
le pubis vers l'avant et
lithium vers l'arrière liliom étant le
losc il ya sur le dessus on va pas s'y
intéresser parce qu'il ya rien qui s'y
passe mais voilà vous avez le pubis vers
l'avant et lisse comme vers l'arrière et
ça ça vous donne un bassin de reptiles
un saut risque bien
et vous avez les ornithischiens qui ont
un bassin d'oiseaux avec le pubis
migrer vers l'arrière coller à l'isq yom
et ça ça vous donne les ornithischiens
et il ya cette histoire qui est très
connu et très intéressante de
convergence évolutif puisque les oiseaux
ont par définition à bas un bassin
d'oiseaux donc un bassin horny titien
alors qu'ils sont descendus des
dinosaures théropodes qui eux avaient un
bassin de ceaurriz tiens donc chez les
dinosaures théropodes en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est que vous aviez à la
base un bassin de ceaurriz tiens donc
que pubis à l'avant ischios mme vers
l'arrière et ce bassin ce pubis a migré
dans l'évolution des théropodes jusqu'à
atteindre une position d'oiseaux donc
jusqu'à la convergence évolutive avec
les ornithischiens est ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant en fait c'est que ben on à
la série évolutive de cette migration
elle est très bien documenté puisque on
a les premiers théropodes dont qui ont à
bassens au risque bien puis on à les
manier raptor rien comme velociraptor
par exemple qui ont un bassin verticale
archéoptéryx aussi un bassin verticale
et puis après on allait les premiers
oiseaux du crétacé comme xxi ornis qui
ont un bassin
en it is qui du coup en éthiciens entre
guillemets puisque le techniquement ce
ne sont pas des ornithischiens c'est une
convergence évolutive et donc là ce
qu'ils ont fait et bien c'est qu'ils ont
regardé des embryons bomba de crocodile
d'une part qui ont effectivement un
bassin de reptiles donc un bassin saulx
risque bien avec le pubis vers l'avant
ici et lisse comme vers l'arrière là
tout va bien et ils ont comparé sa au
développement du bassin des oiseaux chez
les embryons chez les embryons d'oiseaux
et ce qu'ils ont observé et qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'en fait il ya une
sorte bah en fait il y a littéralement
le concept de la fileuse l'ontogénèse
récapitule la phylogénie qui se produit
sur le bassin des oiseaux
là l'image est entré très haute
résolution elle galère de ouf à se
charger mais vous voyez ici donc à
gauche en blanc ici vous avez donc la
série évolutive la phylogénie avec les
premiers archosaures qui ont un bassin
de reptiles pubis vers l'avant et ce
qu'ils aiment vers l'arrière les
premiers dinosaures ici les premiers
dinosaures théropodes avec toujours un
pubis vers l'avant et un
et un ischio sommes vers l'arrière donc
bassin de son risque ya les manières
apte au rien qui ont un pubis verticale
et lisse comme orienté vers l'arrière ce
qui était toujours le cas chez les
premiers oiseaux comme archéoptéryx et
les oiseaux modernes qui ont le le pubis
complètement orientée vers l'arrière et
lisse comme toujours orientés vers
l'arrière donc ça c'est la série
phylogénétique et là vous avez la série
honte aux génériques le développement
donc à droite ici en cours en couleur
verte à peu près donc les premiers les
premiers stades de l'embryon donc ils
sont très très peu aussi fier c'est pour
ça que l'image et peut naître ici vous
montre l'isq le pubis orienté vers
l'avant et lisse comme vers l'arrière
donc les les bébés oiseaux les bébés
poulet ici ont effectivement un bassin
soris tient et on voit le pubis au fur
et à mesure que s'associent fit donc au
fur et à mesure que l'os devient de plus
en plus vers comme vous pouvez le voir
ici ce qui représente l'ossification au
fur et à mesure que le petit poulet le
petit le petit poucet grandi gagne en
maturité en fait on voit le pubis keith
aussi fille et qui migrent vers
l'arrière jusqu'à atteindre la position
chez la position qui est typique des
oiseaux modernes donc récapitulant de
fait le pubis orienté vers la vendée
sort ischia le pubis orientées
verticalement
des manières apte au rien et de
archéoptéryx et ensuite le pubis orienté
complètement vers l'arrière des oiseaux
l'ontt au génie à droite en il
récapitule la phylogénie à gauche en
blanc et ça c'est beau et ça c'est beau
une étude comme ça c'est quand même un
truc de fou alors ça évidemment re
soulevé un débat sur le fameux chicano
aux russes peut-on recréer un dinosaure
à partir d'un petit poulet alors je
rappelle je les ai déjà expliqué dans
une vidéo précédent je rappelle le
projet chicano au russe n'a jamais
jamais jamais eu pour but de recréer un
dinosaure à partir d'un poulet ça c'est
la vitrine la soi-disante création d'un
dinosaure à partir d'embryons de poulet
c'est une vitrine que jack corner a
utilisé pour vendre le projet puisque
l'idée c'est de récolter des fonds et
pour récolter des fonds faut présenter
les choses qui sont sexy donc l'idée de
ressusciter un dinosaure en dévolu en un
embryon de poulet enfin dévolue en un
poulet à partir de l'embryologie c'était
c'était ça l'idée de chicken aux eaux
russes et c'était ça la vitrine de
chicken aux eaux russes l'idée n'a
jamais jamais jamais été en réalité de
recréer à dinosaures à partir d'un
embryon de poulet ça l'idée de chicanos
aux russes ça a toujours été d'étudier
l'embryologie des oiseaux et notamment
des poulets parce que c'est un organisme
modèle est très facilement accessibles
ont produit des milliards
les élevages produisent des milliards
littéralement de poulet donc c'est très
accessible comme matériel biologique
et donc c'est l'idée de ce chicken aux
orris était d'étudier le développement
embryonnaire des poulets pour mieux
comprendre le la génétique des
dinosaures du passé donc le notamment le
développement au meotti comme est basé
sur les hommes et aux jeunes des
dinosaures du passé c'est ça a toujours
été ça c'est delesvaux des veaux on
appelle ça de l'évolution
développementale evo des veaux donc
c'est l'idée c'était de comprendre les
veaux des veaux des dinosaures et
comment quel est le matériel génétique
quels sont les gènes qui s'expriment
pendant ce développement qui permettent
au pubis d'abord d'être orientés vers
l'avant puis ensuite de migrer vers
l'arrière et donc en voyant ce pattern
on et en regardant la séquence
d'activation des gènes on arrive à
comprendre quels sont les changements
génétiques qui ont permis au pubis de
migrer vers l'arrière et de fait de
faire des hypothèses sur quelle était la
condition génétique chez les premiers
dinosaures les dinosaures non aviens ça
c'est le vrai but de chicken aux eaux
russes ceci étant dit chicane aux russes
à ma connaissance n'a pas produit
beaucoup d'articles dé 1 a produit 2 je
crois un sur un sur les doigts et un sur
le pig hostile c'est à dire sur la que
ça cet article là c'est l'équipe de
barta jeanne bullard qu'il l'a publié
donc c'est pas du tout l'équipe chicano
aux ruches et c'était pareil pour
l'article sur les maxillaires sur les
mâchoires il ya une équipe qui avait
réussi à séparer le bec des oiseaux en
deux mâchoires recréant ainsi la
condition présente chez les dinosaures
non aviens ma pareil c'était l'équipe de
barta jeanne bullard pas l'équipe de
jack horner donc en fait ça a rien à
voir cet article n'a absolument rien à
voir avec tiken aux eaux russes et
chicanes aux orris n'a absolument rien à
voir avec une re création potentielle de
dinosaures vos rêves mais mac il écrase
et qu'il est réduit en poussière
je rigole je rigole je rigole et je me
manque un peu aussi c'est vrai on
continue sur les dinosaures toujours les
dinosaures on passe cette fois du côté
ornithischiens de la force du coup
puisqu'on parlait de des changements de
bassins donc ornithischiens de la force
un nouveau dinosaure herbivore publié
dans scientific report donc dans venture
et qui nous décrit à nouveau dinosaure
tiré au fort c'est-à-dire la famille des
sténoses or et des ankylose ans la
famille des dinosaures à armure nouveau
dinosaure à armure qui a cette
particularité d'avoir une silhouette
quand même assez spécial puisque il est
reconstituée comme étant bipèdes voilà
donc son petit nom c'est ce qui est
écrit ici c'est jack à piles
clean your cours à kani okura sont donc
jack à piles can you cour a envoyé à et
reconstitués comme étant une sorte dans
kilos d'or bipèdes ça c'est assez où je
trouve ça a beaucoup fait rêver les
paléo artistes d'imaginer un an qu'ils
osent or be paid alors ceci dit ce n'est
pas un an qu'ils osent or c'est un tir
et au fort basale c'est à dire que vous
avez le groupe dans lequel vous trouvez
les stégosaures et les ankylose or est
en fait ce jack à piles il n'est ni un
steak aux orres ni un an qu'ils osent or
il est le groupe frère en fait il est
juste à l'extérieur c'est ce qu'on
appellerait entre guillemets un ancêtre
en fait c'est l'idée qu'on se fait en
fait jacques à pile c'est l'idée qu'on
se fait de l'ancêtre en commun des
sténoses or et d en kilos d'or
c'est-à-dire descendants des premiers
dinosaures et les premiers dinosaures
était bipède tous les dinosaures était
bipède à la base donc descendants des
premiers dinosaures bipèdes donc
toujours primitivement bipèdes dans sa
posture mais ayant déjà développé ce
début d'armure sur le dos qui va devenir
plus tard l'armure des stégosaure aider
ankylose or et ayant déjà développé de
sérieuses adaptation à l'herbe ivory
notamment on a vu au dessus voyez ses
dents qui ressemble beaucoup à des dents
d'iguane avec ces petites créatures ça
ressemble aussi beaucoup aux dans de
pareilles azor donc c'est vraiment des
dents d'herbivores de reptiles
herbivores les reptiles herbivores ils
ont des dents comme ça exactement qui
ressemble un peu à des feuilles
légèrement dans clé c'est très différent
des mammifères herbivores qui ont des
dents plate pour écraser mais là c'est
vraiment juste des dents qui sont faites
pour couper toute la digestion se passe
dans le système digestif dans le tube
digestif se passe pas dans le haut
niveau de la mastication et vous voyez
cette mâchoire ici alors en blanc c'est
ce que vous c'est ce qu'ils ont
réellement retrouvé sur ce sur cette
silhouette le gris c'est de la
reconstitution raisonnable maintenant
jack à pile il a l'air vachement sympa
vu comme ça mais il faut quand même
modérée son enthousiasme comme je les
dis les parties en blanche c'est ce
qu'on en a retrouvé et donc comme
préciser ici les la distribution des
ostéo derme notamment donc là les
morceaux d'armure que vous voyez là
elle est totalement comme ils disent
spéculatif donc totalement inventés on
ne peut pas savoir exactement comment
ces ostéo derme étaient distribués vous
voyez d'ailleurs que étant donné
l'hétérogénéité des fragments qui ont
été retrouvés ça n'a pas été retrouvée
en articulation tout ça ça a été
retrouvé un petit peu mélangés donc faut
bien aussi garder les pieds sur terre et
moi même je me suis laissé prendre en
partageant au 1 100 kg there be paid
voyez j'ai même appelé le fichier
ankylose or be paid oui alors c'est pas
un an qu'ils osent or c'est un tir et au
fort basale donc ceni à stégosaure
nianan kilos d'or c'est un truc à part
proches parents des ankylose or et des
sténoses or mais pas encore un an kilos
d'or ou un stégosaure et donc la
distribution des ostéo dern là elle est
complètement inventé on n'a aucune idée
de comment il était distribué le
squelette n'a pas été retrouvée articulé
et vous regardez quand même que c'est
largement dominé par le gris notamment
les jambes et les bras est ce qu'il ne
manque pas de nous préciser dans
l'article c'est que effectivement étant
donné le peu qu'on a des jambes et des
bras même l'heureux le reconstituer
bipèdes même là c'est pas sûr donc
finalement il n'était peut-être pas si
bête que ça en réalité ils ont quand
même retrouvé des phalanges donc les
phalanges sont vraiment très très petit
donc il ya de fortes chances que les
bras était est très réduit mais ceci
étant dit faut quand même modérée son
enthousiasme étant donné ce qu'on sait
des jambes et vous voyez qu'on en
connaît très peu de ces fragments de
jambes c'est difficile de mesurer la
longueur des bras et la longueur des
jambes donc en fait peut-être que jack
ap il avait une silhouette beaucoup plus
proche que représenté ici des stégosaure
aider ankylosante donc faut toujours
faire attention quand on voit ces
reconstitutions paléo artistique faut
toujours faire attention quand on voit
des images comme ça qu'ils sont très
très
ça c'est quand même super sexy comme
représentation mais faut pas perdre de
vue quand même que le matériel est très
fragmentaire et que même les auteurs
sont pas allées sont pas allés jusqu'à
dire que le machin était bipède c'est
certain on en a aucun doute non même eu
dans l'article 10 ouais même bipèdes
c'est probablement bipèdes parce que ces
primes ifec primitivement le tous les
dinosaures était bipède mais en réalité
voilà c'est pas sûr du tout et enfin
pour terminer avec les dinosaures
d'angeac ans jacques ou la revue géo
diversitas ce donc la revue du muséum
d'histoire naturelle de paris a publié
le grand passage en revue de tout le
matériel qui a été découvert en jacques
en tout cas le matériel de vertébrés et
c'est c'est un très très longue article
très très bien illustré par mme hazan
mme hazan qui nous regardent donc je le
jeu le salut est donc cet article décrit
la quasi-totalité du matin en tout cas
résume la quasi totalité du matériel qui
a été découvert sur le site c'est un
article qui est vraiment très complet
très touffu
donc j'ai pas la prétention de vous en
faire un résumé là comme ça je vous le
mets en descriptions évidemment pour que
vous puissiez le télécharger et le lire
par vous même je vais juste attirer
votre attention donc sur le c7 cette
diversité qu'ils ont retrouvé donc sur
ce site de angeac charente
avec donc une diversité du début du
crétacé
et cette diversité du début du crétacé
voyez locke cette large domination par
les ornithologues aux or on a mis des
aloses ory des aloses euro id on a on a
même un tout petit peu de tyrannosaure
aux ide vous voyez six spécimens quand
même de tyrannosaure aux ide et on a des
sauropodes évidemment le grand sauropode
d'angeac est très connu mais on
ad'autres sauropodes qui appartiennent
apparemment à la famille des curiaces or
d'autres reptiles divers et variés des
tortues des crocodiles des folies dozos
rider et même quelques autres dinosaures
herbivores parmi des iguanodon idées les
tirer aux forts etc etc et aussi une
diversité d'animaux plus petit bon
évidemment des poissons puisque tout
tous dépôts de fossiles se passe dans un
environnement plus ou moins à que donc
on n'est pas on seront ne se pose pas
vraiment la question de savoir si oui ou
non il va ya voir des poissons
généralement il y en a toujours on a
même des chondrites ya donc des poissons
cartilagineux et on a
fait notable des petits mammifères il ya
des petits mammifères qui ont été
trouvés à angeac charente on a tendance
à beaucoup parlé des dinosaures mais il
ya du petit mammifère qui a été trouvé
en jacques charente et je vais vous en
montrer peut-être une petite figure
parce que ça alors c'est des mammifères
évidemment ils ne sont pas représentés
par du très gros matériel là s'est
identifié comme étant des micros des
micros reste c'est mammifères
d'angeac-charente voyez ce sont des
dents mais voyez il n'y a pas de doute
sur le fait que cette petite dent à 3
caunes organisant en triangle c'est ce
qu'on appelle tribos phoenix n'y a pas
de doute sur le fait que ça c'est à
partir d'une mammifères et donc il ya
aussi des mammifères du mésozoïque qui
vivait en jacques charente en tout petit
nombre mais c'est quand même super
intéressant donc voilà je vous invite à
lire cet article qui est très très bien
très bien écrit et très complet si vous
voulez tout savoir du site de angeac
charente et pour terminer avec les
dinosaures voici un nouvel article paru
dans nature's grandes revues de sciences
en général qui nous parle donc de
l'évolution du métabolisme chez les
dinosaures donc notamment du métabolisme
à sang chaud la fameuse endothermique et
c'est viêt-nam non pardon vivier man
jasmin aviez man qu'il a publié avec ses
collègues alors jasmin aviez man je vous
en avais parlé dans un palais aux news
il ya très longtemps c'est la chercheuse
la paléontologue qui parvient à
reconstituer les protéines sur des
fossiles dont on s'imaginait pas qu'il
contenait des protéines donc est là elle
a une méthode qu'elle a publiée il ya
longtemps il ya deux ans maintenant je
crois voire même trois donc elle a
inventé une nouvelle méthode qui permet
d'extraire des protéines de fossiles
dont on ne s'imaginait pas qu'il
conservait des protéines et de
reconstituer ces protéines alors c'est
pas jurassic park un cd protéines c'est
pas de l'adn mais grâce à ces protéines
ce qu'elle arrive à faire en fait c'est
à
quantifier la dégradation de ces
protéines et en fait ce qu'on constate
c'est que chez les animaux à sang chaud
les protéines vont se dégrader d'une
façon différente de chez les animaux à
sang froid et donc elle a réussi en
mesurant cette dégradation protéique
chez les animaux moderne et en la
comparant avec ceux qu'elle trouvait
dans les ossements fossilisés donc à
partir des protéines qu'elle arrive à
reconstituer
de
dinosaures notamment b à l'arrêt qu'on
réussi à reconstituer en fait cet arbre
donc cet arbre qui nous indique la
transition vers un métabolisme élevé
chez les dinosaures je zoome un petit
peu pour que vous puissiez voir
donc voilà les oiseaux ici tout en haut
de l'arbre avec un métabolisme qui est
donc très élevé un plus on tend vers le
rouge plus on a un métabolisme élevé ici
on a les dinosaures théropodes
tyrannosaurus à le zoo russe ici on a
dit paul ii un diplôme de sid et donc
qui est un sort ischia aux côtés des
théropodes
ici mais est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant
en fait c'est qu'elle reconstitue une
origine de landau thermie
commune aux ptérosaures et aux
dinosaures est en fait pour elle les
ornithischiens ont des protéines qui
montre un pattern de dégradations
typique des des animaux plus à sang
froid voyez que la branche ici passent
du jaune au vert ce qui nous ramène vers
un métabolisme plus tôt à sang froid et
donc elle parle d'en dégoter remise
secondaire c'est à dire qu'il était en
d'autres termes et ils ont perdu cette
faculté à être en d'autres termes les
dinosaures herbivores
l'explication est temps que c'était
probablement une adaptation un régime
alimentaire beaucoup moins riche
puisque les dinosaures étaient
primitivement tous carnivores ou au
moins un omnivore et donc les
ornithischiens se sont adaptés à ce
régime plus herbivores donc moins riches
en nutriments moins riches en graisses
animales notamment et c'est pour ça
qu'ils seraient redevenus ectothermes
ceci étant dit le diplo décidé à
métabolisme super élevé donc je sais pas
jusqu'à quel point cette
va falloir évidemment un peu plus qu'un
seul qu'un seul
sauropodes pour pour vérifier évidemment
que ça fonctionne ou pas chez les
sauropodes mais je trouve ça très
intéressant en fait c'est vraiment une
approche très nouvelle puisque comme je
dis on se base sur des protéines des
trucs qui devrait pas être préservés
notamment
normalement chez nous chez chez nos
fossiles et pourtant elle arrive à les
reconstituer donc ça c'est quand même
assez assez dingue
elle reconstitue aussi du coup que les
crocodiles
sont devenus aussi seconde herman
ectothermes donc ça c'était assez
cohérent avec déjà des preuves qu'on
avait trouvé par ailleurs chez les
crocodiles modernes notamment le fait
qu'ils ont un coeur à 4 cavité au lieu
de deux ça c'est très typique
normalement des andes au terme mais les
crocodiles malgré le fait qu'ils soient
ectothermes ont toujours un coeur à 4
cavités et ça
c'était ça a été interprété comme le
signe que les ancêtres des crocodiles
étaient peut-être en d'autres termes bon
ben là cette étude tend à confirmer cela
et là où ça devient intéressant c'est
que elle a quand même inclus ainsi nappe
side alors à l'époque
j'avais cru je croyais que ce synappci
d' serait dit métro dont en réalité
c'était et da foz aux russes donc elle a
inclus des synapses id tous les
mammifères modernes enfin un bon
échantillonnage de mammifères modernes
qui sont tous en de termes et aida photo
russe donc pour l'instant il n'y a pas
vraiment de ne pas voir ya pas vraiment
de quoi dire que les de quoi pointer du
doigt est ce assez l'origine de landau
termine chez les synapses id mais ceci
dit ça donne de l'espoir parce que si on
arrive à retrouver des protéines des da
foz aux russes c'est à dire de trucs qui
ont quasiment 300 millions d'années
parce que là les dinosaures la sas et
c'est des trucs du crétacé et du
jurassique ça c'est pas vieux comparé à
et d'infos au russe et d'un photo
réussie les deux fois plus vieux qu'eux
donc si on arrive à reconstituer des
protéines vieille de 300 millions
d'années franchement
j'attends de voir la suite je lui ai
envoyé un email jasmin aviez manne pour
lui demander si elle avait l'intention
de faire ça sur les synapses it sur plus
de synapses id j'ai pas eu de réponse
mais ça me semble trop évident que ça me
semble trop évident que c'est la
prochaine étape quoi donc j'espère
réellement que cette technique va
continuer à être employée est testé sur
les synapses id parce qu'on a vraiment
besoin de savoir si les synapses il
était en d'autres termes et à quel
moment surtout les synapses ide ont
commencé à devenir en d'autres termes
justement
mon collègue ricardo et mon autre
collègue romain david donc ricardo qui
vient du portugal et romain david qui
est qui a fait sa thèse à paris mais qui
est maintenant à londres ont publié avec
toute une équipe toute une flopée de
gens dont moi voilà c'est mon petit nom
ici donc gg j'ai eu le bonheur de
contribuer à ce nouvel article paru dans
nature's sur justement aussi l'évolution
de landau termine mais cette fois chez
les synapses c'est là la transition
parfaite
quand est ce que les synapses ils sont
devenus à sang chaud alors nous on n'a
pas étudié les protéines puisque comme
je les dis jasmin avis émane n'a pas
encore jeté son dévolu sur les synapses
in nous par contre ce qu'on a utilisé
ses la morphologie de l'oreille interne
l'oreille interne qui est remplie d'un
liquide qui s'appelle landes olaf et
donc pour que votre oreille interne
fonctionne notamment l'organe de
l'equilibre vous avez l'organe de
l'équilibré l'organe de l'audition dans
l'oreille donc ici ce sont les canots
semi circulaire l'organe de l' équilibre
pour que ça fonctionne bien faut que
l'an d'olaf le liquide qui se trouve à
l'intérieur
soit une viscosité
d'une certaine viscosité et le truc
c'est que quand on devient à l'animal à
sang chaud bas par définition la
température du corps augmente donc la
température de l'an d'olaf augmente donc
comme le miel comme quand vous
réchauffer du miel ou comme quand vous
réchauffer du nutella par exemple eh
bien ça devient plus liquides moins
visqueux et de fait ça perturbe le
fonctionnement de votre organe de votre
organe de l' équilibre et l'intuition
absolument géniale de romain ça a été de
dire et si si l'organe de l' équilibre
est perturbée par le changement de
viscosité
delande olaf
est ce qu'il y aurait pas moyen de
tracer sa dans le registre fossile est
ce qui aurait pas moyen de tracer ce
changement de viscosité sur la
morphologie de l'oreille interne eh ben
ça a marché parce que l'oreille interne
c'est un organe qu'il faut s'y lisent
très bien et que ce que romain et
ricardo a pointé du doigt bas c'est que
l'oreille interne des mammifères s'est
adapté à ce changement de viscosité en
devenant notamment plus petit c'est ce
qu'on voit là là c'est les mammifères
lasser les terres apside donc elle est
devenue plus petit et avec des canaux
beaucoup plus gracile beaucoup plus
étroit parce qu'évidemment si votre en
dollars se réchauffe elle devient plus
liquides donc soit vous pouvez changer
la chimie de votre en dollars mais c'est
pas ça que les mammifères au fait ça
c'est ce que les oiseaux ont fait par
contre les mammifères eux ce qu'ils ont
fait c'est qu'ils ont juste réduit le
diamètre des tuyaux des canots semi
circulaires et donc du coup le
changement de viscosité est compensée
par des tuyaux plus petits
ça rend de fait ça compense en fait le
fait que l'en de l'avs soit plus liquide
et donc en traçant cette évolution
depuis des canots semi circulaire plutôt
large plutôt robustes plutôt grand verre
des canots semi circulaire plus petit
plus étroit et bien ils ont réussi à
pointer du doigt exactement quand un
métabolisme à sang chaud est apparu
quand est ce que la température des
mammifères
enfin des ancêtres des mammifères a
changé pour devenir une température
d'animal à sang chaud les mammifères ont
une température qui qui va varier entre
30 et 40 degrés à peu près les expos
termes modernes ils ont une température
qui varie plus entre 17 et 40 degrés
alors il peut y avoir des ectothermes
très chaud par définition les
ectothermes de toute façon température
en accordéon et qui va changer tout le
temps
mais en moyenne du coût parce que votre
en dollars elle va pas s'adapter à
toutes les températures elle va
s'adapter à la température moyenne donc
en moyenne les mammifères ont une
température corporelle plus chaude que
les ectothermes et donc votre en dollars
va être plutôt adapté à cette
température moyenne à laquelle votre
corps l'habitude de flirter avec voyez
elle va pas s'adapter à toutes les
différentes températures c'est pas
possible donc votre ado la fallait
adapter à sa part sélection naturelle et
donc on arrive enfin ricardo et romain
et puis tous les autres contributeurs de
cet article ont permis de reconstituer
cette transition depuis une en d'olaf
relative indiqué enfin depuis une
morphologie de l'oreille interne
indiquant un an de la une en dollars
plus tôt visqueuse jusqu'à une
morphologie de l'oreille interne
indiquant que l'an de l'afld était
plutôt liquide et grâce à ça ils ont
permis de pointer du doigt le groupe de
danse être des mammifères chez qui tout
a changé chez qui tout a basculé la date
233 millions d'années c'est très précis
ça s'est passé très très vite il ya 233
millions d'années et ça s'est passé chez
ce qu'on appelle les maliens morph à
savoir les sino d'hondt les plus dérivés
ceux qui sont les plus proches des
mammifères les
notamment les treaty l'odon idées et les
triplés well et treaty l'odon idée
brasil y terium et brazil aux dons
peut-être et alors que les traiter l'eau
dont idées comme rio grande ya eu était
encore à sang froid voiliers qui s'ils
sont encore en bleu donc c'est arrivé
relativement tard dans l'histoire des
sino donc mais c'est quand même arrivé
avant l'origine des mammifères les
premiers mammifères et en had rocco diom
et morganucodon ici un truc adro codiam
morganucodon aimer aimer gaz austro dont
ici donc c'est à les premiers mammifères
qui sont apparus ya à peu près 200 205
millions d'années donc on est à peu près
30 millions d'années avant l'origine des
mammifères pour l'origine de landau
terme y ait là où c'est formidable c'est
qu'il a même réussi à pointer du doigt
la température dégâts donc ici rio
grande ya et les ancêtres des mammifères
les tous les signaux dont etc il avait
une température d'à peu près 24 degrés
et la celle et treaty l'odon idée on a
une température qui monte soudainement a
à peu près 33 34 degrés donc c'est pas
encore la température des mammifères
placentaires moderne qui flirte
évidemment dans l'ordre des 37 degrés
comme vous le savez
c'est pas encore la température des
mammifères modernes mais c'est déjà un
bon vous voyez c'est un bond
significatif
dans la température corporelle c'est
quasiment quasiment 10 degrés en un
million d'années et ça ça contraste
vraiment avec ce qu'on croyait savoir
avant avant ben je vous avais expliqué
dans ma vidéo sur l'évolution de landau
termine l'année dernière que pour ce
qu'on en savait on bat on savait rien
c'est à dire que tous les signaux
étaient contradictoires
pour la simple et bonne raison qu'en
fait on n'avait pas d'indicatif direct
de la température on a juste des
corrélations avec des structures hausse
théologique plus ou moins étroitement
lié avec l'évolution du métabolisme mais
on n'avait pas de n'avait pas vraiment
comme l'oreille interne lala ce qui est
formidable c'est qu'avec cette oreille
interne 7 on a vraiment une adaptation
directe un changement de température et
c'est pour ça justement que ricardo et
romain ont réussi à mettre le doigt sur
la temps le changement de température
ils peuvent vous dire c'est sinon donc
là les anciens s'ils nous donnent les
plus anciens et les terras psid il
devait avoir une température de 24
degrés alors que c'est sinon donc la
lema mali amorphe treaty l'aude anti
d'être et brasil dont brasil aux dons ty
et le il devait avoir une température de
34 degrés c'est parce que l'oreille
interne est directement reliée à la
température
alors ça évidemment c je vous donne la
version facile mais il ya évidemment
c'est un peu plus technique que ça en
tout cas ce qu'il ya d'intéressant ouais
c'est que ce changement il s'est passé
très vite contrairement à ce qu'on
pensait savoir parce que comme on avait
un signal tellement diffus avant
tellement contradictoires de tous ces
corps et la hausse théologique allant de
terreau me bats on pensait que landau
terme yale avaient évolué très lentement
et que c'est pour ça qu'on voyait rien
en fait et en réalité bas ce que nous
suggère cette nouvelle étude est bien
c'est que finalement peut-être qu'on
regardait juste au mauvais endroit et
que c'est pour ça qu'on voyait rien non
c'est parce qu'on aurait dû regarder
l'oreille atteint donc cette intuition
géniale
d'utiliser la viscosité de l'an olaf
pour reconstituer le changement de
température c'est du caviar c'est
franchement roma david
je suis fan voilà je suis fan je vais
créer un fan-club de romain david et
regarder l'asse ce fameux changement là
233 millions d'années on passe d'une
température dectot terme donc les
crocodiles et les pizzas rien qui
soudainement à une température
équivalente à celle des mots notres m et
les mammifères placentaires et
marsupiaux ayant une température encore
plus élevé donc là c'est ce que je
disais de l'ordre de 34 degrés il arrive
même à dire qu'ils étaient à 34 degrés
les machins là qu'est ce que vous voulez
de mieux donc là c'est vraiment ouais
c'est alors c'est une étude cet article
il est vraiment pas facile à lire mais
on en a fait des résumés à droite et à
gauche il ya notamment un résumé qui va
sortir très bientôt dans nos
conversations enfin dans la conversation
du coup en français
conversation canada donc pareil fait ma
pensée si je vous ai pas mis le lien
dans la description faite moi penser ça
donne un résumé relativement simple de
cette étude mais cette étude cet article
là sinon il est très très très compliqué
à lire il est très très technique les
images sont jolis ceci vous pouvez
regarder les images les images je trouve
parle d'elle-même elle sont pas
seulement jolie mais je veux dire elle
parle d'elle-même on voit bien on voit
bien ici le changement de température du
bleu au rouge dans quelques l'adsa a
lieu et on voit bien ici pas c'est
pareil la température moyenne qui passe
de
deux ce qu'on voit chez les ectothermes
pou soudainement à ce qu'on voit chez
les ados terme il y à 233 millions
d'années ce qui est intéressant aussi
c'est qu'à 233 millions d'années on a
une crise biologique qui s'appelle la
crise plus via la crise pluviales du
canadien donc il ya soudainement il
s'est mis à faire très humide on se
demande s'il aurait pas un lien avec ça
peut-être peut-être pas
tout cas voilà et il ya une vidéo aussi
qui va sortir bientôt j'ai fait une
interview de romain david qui nous
explique plus en détail tout ce qu'il y
a tout ce qu'il ya dans cet article est
compris des aspects plus techniques que
je ne suis pas capable moi-même
d'expliquer parce que soyons tout à fait
honnête le travail que j'ai fait sur cet
article était essentiellement un travail
de technicien
les les maths qui est que romain et
riccardo muti lisez les équations sont
beaucoup trop venu pour moi
j'ai pris je suis très content d'avoir
participé à cet article mais soyons tout
à fait honnête j'ai pris une grosse
baffe d'humilité dans ma gueule
en le lisant ça c'est clair enfin en y
contribuant je veux dire et à chaque
fois que je le relis je prends une
grosse baffe d'humilité dans ma gueule
donc mais en tout cas je suis super
content d'y avoir participé il faudra
voir si jasmin aviez man
utilise sa technique basée sur les
protéines sur les synapses it voir si on
trouve des résultats cohérents ce serait
super que ce soient les résultats soient
cohérents en tout cas là les résultats
qu'on a là ils sont cohérents avec
ce que j'avais fait en 2016 sur
l'évolution des poils c'est j'avais
étudié l'évolution du système nerveux
des synapses ide et j'avais montré que
du coup les moustaches qui sont des
poils
sont apparus bah justement chez les ch
et ces signaux de traits dérivés
mammalian mali amorphe
en tout cas les moustaches était apparu
peut-être juste un petit peu avant lé
mali amorphe plus de 140 plutôt que 230
millions d'années mais c'est du même
ordre de grandeur à peu près au même
endroit aussi dans l'arbre
phylogénétique
et du coup ça a indiqué dans mon article
j'indiquais bas que l'origine des
moustaches il ya 240 241 millions
d'années
tendrait à indiquer que le matériel
génétique pour fabriquer des poils est
apparu à ce moment là et donc ou qui dit
poile dit fourrure et idy fourrure dix
ans de permis et que donc on ne serait
pas surpris de voir landau terme y
évoluer à peu près au même endroit au
niveau 2 au même endroit phylogénétique
je veux dire chez les mêmes espèces que
celle qui pour la première fois
développe un système nerveux comme kiki
indicatif de la présence de moustache
est bien là en plein dedans
ba en pleines dents donc c'est assez
formidable je trouve ça je trouve ça
très émotionnel et je j'ai vraiment très
hâte qu'on rajoute plus de deux
spécimens à ses analyses et j'étais
vraiment très hâte que ricardo et romain
face ça sur les oiseaux mais ça on vous
en parle on vous en parle plus en détail
dans la vidéo l'interview l'interview de
roma david donc je vais pas spoiler ça
toujours dans les synapses id la
description d'un nouveau synappci de
casa idée de france du bassin de lodève
donc il nous vient des ruf du lodévois
ces fameuses terres rouges du lodévois
et s'est représenté en rouge mais je
vous montre les photos voilà les terres
rouges les russes du lodévois qui datent
du permien moyens et qui ont des livres
est donc un nouveau squelette de casey
idée alors il y avait déjà des restes
fossiles qui avaient été trouvés vous
voyez là dans ses ruches du lodévois
mais là on a donc à nouveau quasi idées
dont vous pouvez voir l'humérus ici une
vertèbre là et qui a été baptisé lalieux
doha cus donc le nez de la lieude parce
que baracus parce que les caser idée on
a cette espèce de gros pif et lalieux
dos parce que c'est la localité qui
s'appelle la lieude si vous connaissez
la région du lodévois vous avez
certainement vu les empreintes de la
lieue de donc cette dalle à empreintes
protégés sous un hangar et bien ça a été
trouvé juste à côté et donc voilà une
reconstitution du squelette de la lieude
or accusent alors ça n'a pas l'air
d'être grand chose d'ailleurs j'ai dit
humérus mais avant c'était un fémur
autant pour moi je suis allé un peu vite
nancy c'est un numerus c'est un humérus
là c'est la crête des ltte pectoral je
sais pas pourquoi il n'est pas
représenté ou alors il est caché il est
caché sous la sous la ceinture
scapulaire peut-être mais bref la lieude
or accusent donc nouveau casey idée de
france et alors qu'il ya cette
particularité d'avoir
alors les caser idée c'était des
herbivores c'était des synapses id
herbivores ça ressemble un peu à un
heddaf aux orres si vous voyez un peu ce
à quoi ressemblait daf other c'est un
peu ça ressemble à un état faisant sa
une toute petite tête c'est un énorme
corps donc une énorme chambre de
fermentation en guise de de thorax une
toute petite tête et
ça diffère des et da foz or par
l'absence de crédit dorsale donc c'était
des animaux vraiment très bizarre avec
vraiment une toute petite très chou et
en classe qu'ils ont fait c'est qu'ils
ont fait des études histologique est
alors ses études histologique voyez que
ça donne quand même un tissu osseux un
peu bizarre il ya voyez il n'y a pas
vraiment de séparation entre
régions corticales et régions médullaire
voyez sa transition entre régions
corticales à la surface et régions
médullaire au milieu de façon assez
basses et continue en fait on n'y a pas
de limitation de limites très distinctes
entre la régions corticales et la région
médullaire et ça c'est un truc qu'on
retrouve chez certaines espèces
aquatiques
notamment les plus aquatiques comme les
espèces pélagiques réellement et ça
c'est vraiment bizarre ça c'est vraiment
bizarre et ça suggère de fait que la
lieude haut-rhin cus était un animal
aquatique voyez là vous voyez une très
belle reconstitution de la lieue doha
cus en train de nager
il ya d'autres hypothèses qui suggère
que la llodra cus était plutôt un animal
fouisseurs donc qui creusait vous voyez
qu'il a des grosses m'a alors là les
grosses mains sont reconstitués comme
étant des nageoires on peut aussi
considérer que les grosses mains servait
à creuser il avait une hypothèse qui
avaient été soulevées à propos des cases
et idée qui était qu'en fait ils ont une
seconde une ceinture scapulaire donc des
épaules tellement massive et une tête
tellement petites qu'en fait la tête
aurait pu à peine atteindre le sol s'il
avait s'il avait penché et du coup la
grande question c'est est mais comment
ils buvaient cet animal s'ils pouvaient
pas penché la tête alors l'une des
hypothèses basses et qu'il se mettait
dans l'eau pour boire et parce que
c'était un animal aquatique de fait il
n'y avait pas vraiment de contraintes
motrice
pour aller boire puisqu'il vivait de
toute façon tout le temps dans l'eau en
réalité donc ça c'est une des hypothèses
de vie des cases et idée soutenue par ce
nouveau spécimen lalieux dorin cus
venue du permien des ruf de lodève on
vous en reparle avec l'un des auteurs
dans une vidéo qui va sortir bientôt
alors l'un des auteurs qui est josselin
falconnet spécialiste des synappci de
france est donc resté rester avec nous
dans les prochaines semaines puisqu'il
ya une interview de jocelyn falconnet où
on va parler très très très en détail de
tous nos collègues les synapses ide qui
ont été retrouvés en france et pour
terminer avec les synapses id on va
maintenant parler du genre homo donc des
synapses hic traits dérivés puisqu'il
s'agit de mammifères donc le genre homo
dont la fondation atapuerca sur son site
internet donc c'est pas publiés dans une
revue scientifique à comité de lecture
mais la fondation à table atapuerca sur
son site internet a annoncé la
découverte dans la cimade al elefante
donc la
montagne des éléphants
la découverte des plus anciens restes
humains européen date et à savoir des
restes du genre homo probablement et
d'albert guentis daté de 1.4 millions
d'années et donc ils ont fourni une
photo avec ça voici la photo de ces
restes humains de 1,4 million d'années
de la cimade l éléphante et donc voyez
c'est il s'agit d'un petit bout de
maxillaire ici avec ici le début de
l'arcade jus galles et la laure bits
donc on a c'est juste un tout petit bout
pour l'instant c'est pas grand chose
mais c'est identifiables comme et
appartenant au genre homo et si cela se
confirme et si la datation se confirme
et bien ce sera le plus ancien du
courant s'être de néandertal puisque à
la cimade l éléphante et c'est ce qu'ils
ont ils ont de l'homo heidelbergensis
donc finalement les homo erectus tout
fraîchement sortis d'afrique puisque la
sortie d'afrique et datés à 2 millions
d'années donc des homo erectus tout
fraîchement sortis d'afrique qui ont
commencé à devenir des prêts entre et
néandertaliens donc homo heidelbergensis
et pour terminer ce paléo news on reste
avec le genre homo mais cette fois on se
déplace vers la chine on va finir avec
les les humains de chine et notamment le
ce de la caverne auxerre alors les
humaine la caverne auxerre je vous mets
une petite image
maintenant voilà ça c'est les humains de
la caverne auxerre donc céder
c'est un ce sont des crânes n'y a pas
qu'un seul crâne mais ce sont des crânes
et des mandibules qui ont été retrouvés
en chine qui ont à peu près 14 mille ans
donc ils sont relativement jeunes je
veux dire 14 mille ans on est allé on
est à l'orée du néolithique à on est
vraiment à la toute fin de la dernière
ère glaciaire
donc c'est vraiment très très jeune et
donc ces crânes de 14 mille ans ils ont
un truc c'est qu'il ressemble pas tant
que ça à des êtres humains modernes
alors ils ont effectivement un front
très très plat comme nous comme les
êtres humains modernes ils ont un petit
menton comme les êtres humains modernes
mais alors par contre les arcades rue
galles elles sont hyper épaisse et les
dents sont légèrement plus grosses alors
rien à voir avec denisot va et les
néandertal ne sont pas grosses à ce
point là mais les dents sont quand même
très très grosse pour de l'homo sapiens
et donc il y avait une grande question
sur bas c'est qui c'est c'est qui ce
peuple de la caverne auxerre
certains l'appellent l'homme de ma du
longue ouais vous voyez mal du langues
c'est exactement ça donc il ya des
chercheurs qui ont fait des analyses
génétiques donc ils ont réussi à
extraire de l'adn de ces crânes qui ont
conduite des analyses génétiques qui les
ont comparés à d'autres crâne chinois et
a évidemment à de l'adn dumas moderne
bas que c'était bien de l'humain moderne
donc l'homme de ma du longue aussi
bizarre soit il
reste un humain moderne et d'ailleurs
ils ont profité aussi de cette nouvelle
analyse génétique pour comparer l'adn
des peuples sud est asiatique à aux
peuples d'amérique du nord et donc ce
qu'ils ont trouvé c'est que les peuples
du sud est asiatique et de l'amérique du
nord
sont génétiquement très proche donc ce
qui confirme l'origine est asiatique des
êtres humains d'amérique du nord donc la
migration par le détroit de béring bon
tout ça c'est publiée dans current
biology grande revue de biologie et de
génétique qui démontre finalement et
bien que l'homme de ma du l'ongle
l'homme de la caverne auxerre est bel et
bien un homo sapiens comme indiqué par
son front plat et son petit manteau son
petit menton proéminent voilà c'était
paléo news je vous remercie de l'avoir
suivi n'oubliez pas de vous abonner pour
ne rien manquer d'anciens et je vous dis
à très bientôt
[Musique]